and i'd i'd like to try it all again
i really would the pirates of the
caribbean goes down as one of the
greatest adventure film franchises of
all time we certainly had a good time
watching them and the cast had a great
time making them so let's play a game
who had the most line flubs be sure to
pay attention we're keeping count
number one sometimes there's that one
line that trips every actor up do you
have the courage and fortitude to follow
what is this day
and johnny depp certainly got a lot of
them while playing jack sparrow do you
have the courage to afford it
hey jack here's the solution maybe just
try laying off the rum a little god i
hate this bloody line where the writers
i'm gonna kill them number two this one
should really serve as major props to
jonathan price for keeping us cool
[Music]
because it really didn't seem like
orlando bloom was confident with his
sword tricks
[Music]
not saying will turner didn't give it
his all but oh my careful of the face
there bloom
[Music]
impressive number three hanging around
disney pirates too much can just make
you a little tongue-tied he still rips
his life
being on a ship with long shoot days can
also do a big number on your speech
maybe the cast listened well during
acting class and are just warming up
those muscles that's definitely more
probable than any of the casts just
flubbing lines right
number four elizabeth swann may have
taken this one a little too all the way
for this little improv session might i
shove you for something to wear
or will it be bear breasts and ankles
all the way but that's no big deal for
us in the present day yes but oh was
this inappropriate to say to a commodore
[Music]
the best part is the fact that she
realized what she said immediately and
just caused a laughing fit amongst the
two
number five sometimes even the simplest
actions can be flubbed up by an actor
[Music]
not saying this was price's fault or
anything but we always thought the lamp
fixture was broken by accident and
placed in the final cut for humor
[Laughter]
leave it to an actor to never
intentionally break a prop
say that last night again number six
orlando's got a grunting problem
we don't know if it's just a case of a
lack of water or just trying to be all
tough around the pirates
but somebody just needs to get him
something to drink
number seven johnny really got into the
character of jack sparrow and more than
a few times he would just forget his
lines is to climb aboard the davy jones
rocket machine or whatever it's called
what's the bloody thing called this time
was a very confusing moment for all of
us
you knew this i did not
number eight being able to roll with the
punches on set is no easy feat and when
things can go wrong on set they always
will
sorry
so of course the great jack will turn a
strange sound into something humorous we
couldn't expect anything less than that
are you certain
number nine depp seemed to have all of
the hard lines you can keep barbosa the
belligerent homunculus and his sticky
wooden friend
real props this time should go to his
fellow actors for actually keeping it
together throughout multiple takes i'll
get it this time i promise don't worry
johnny was the one in the end who would
ultimately laugh at his own mess-ups
number 10 tom hollander and johnny depp
are probably the biggest goofball duo to
work in a scene
[Music]
from hollander just not being able to
handle the whole sparrow persona and
honestly the same reason for depp these
two really tested the crew's patience
tossing two objects back and forth seems
like a generally simple task but we
think they may have not thrown things a
whole lot in their careers
number 11 we feel like we could always
remember one lesson growing up it was to
never play with sharp objects our
intentions are strictly honorable
it might seem off to be paid to do so
and in this case to do so in the most
extreme way
strictly honorable
you can see their fears and frustrations
trying to pull this off but the moment
they finally do now that was just pure
joy on barbosa's face
[Applause]
number 12. sometimes actors will just
get too caught up with the designs of
the set and this time kevin mcnally got
too caught up in a different way like a
bit of crossbreed
sorry i got caught up this one's not
really kevin's fault all he had to do
was walk down the stairs the other two
actors had no idea at first what was
going on
like a bit of cross breeze
number 13. one question for you jeffrey
rush got eyepatch action
oh
but obviously it wasn't as bad as it
looks because there's no way they'd pass
up on this opportunity to have a pirate
with the signature eye patch
that's powerful
number 14 there's only one thing in
common with the second goofball duo and
that's captain jack i'm touched at this
moment
johnny just can't ever get it together
for the simplest moments
[Music]
to be fair though he was just trying to
do it right but it was not working out
for him i think the state's going very
well don't you
number 15 jack sparrow has this
particular look that makes even some of
the most veteran actors corpse on set
we definitely don't blame them and we
can be sure depp is having the time of
his life here what are you laughing at
maybe next time just get all the
laughter out before a jack sparrow scene
number 16 when the peg leg doesn't fit
you just got to keep trying for the
scene
get in there
we got to wonder if this was ever a real
problem for pirates back in the day
except this time at least rush didn't
have to worry about constant impending
doom and could really take his time on
it alas the only real solution here is
that you just gotta give up on it
no it's broken can't help you mate i
don't want to touch it number 17 the
giggle duo strikes again and at this
point we have no clue what they're
laughing at
[Music]
we've all been there though long days
equal fits of laughter that never stop
[Laughter]
with how many outtakes there are of this
moment how in the scurvy did they ever
finally pull this off
[Music]
number 18. seriously folks this one's
pure satire we think everyone would know
to never take sword handling advice from
captain jack sparrow
i hit the ceiling i caught the ceiling
so we thought we'd just throw that
disclaimer out there we can say that
depp is simply demonstrating how
difficult it is to fight with one
nine
number 19. are we supposed to believe
celebrities have eyes in the back of
their heads
this smack was just put off a little too
much
[Music]
it's all going terribly well
number 20 monkey see monkey don't
come on monkey
[Music]
come on
yep we're going to let you decide who
messed this one up
[Music]
tonight
the two jacks just didn't put aside
their differences from the earlier films
grudges can make for an unprofessional
experience today
today today's the night
oh thank you we hope the chemistry
wasn't lost at this point and hope jack
apologized to jack after shooting was
done there were so many bloopers in the
making of this franchise
that we still can't imagine how they
ended up with such great final results
all egos had to stay at the door here
because no matter how talented you are
messing up a scene was just the trendy
thing so we hope you've been paying
attention who had the most line flubs
comment your answer below and thanks for
watching the things